what's one of the biggest mistakes a
pilot can make according to the FAA
Runway incursions are some of the
biggest contributors to aircraft
accidents and today on free pilot
training I'm going to explain some of
the things you need to know to keep you
from having a Runway
incursion welcome to Free pilot training
I'm Josh and today we're talking about
runway incursions in a nutshell a rly
incursion is when you're somewhere you
shouldn't be at an airport as you can
imagine being somewhere where you
shouldn't be can be extremely dangerous
many aircraft have crashed into each
other because one or both of them were
in the wrong place at the wrong time
because of that it's very important that
you know some of the basic signs
markings and lighting that you may see
at an airport now the FAA has worked
very hard to make all this stuff as
simple as possible because they know how
important it is to prevent accidents and
in the last few years they've really
been focusing on standardizing all this
stuff so the signs you see at a big
airport will be the same signs you see
at a smaller airport now typically
you'll see more of this stuff at a big
airport but we're still going to go over
all of it because you can legally fly
into a bunch of these places once you
get your Private Pilot certificate first
things first let's take a look at
something called a location sign notice
that this sign is black with yellow
letters this is literally where you are
on the Airfield now for some reason a
lot of instructors don't ever mention
this I guess they think it's common
sense but I think it's important for us
to talk about take a look at this
taxiway diagram from adamsfield in
Little Rock Arkansas by by the way when
you're taxing it's extremely important
that you have this diagram up at all
times this will keep you from getting
lost especially at Big airfields anyway
notice that all these taxi ways have
letters associated with them or letters
and numbers these are the names of the
taxiways so if I'm on taxiway Bravo
right here I'm going to see a big black
sign with a big yellow B on it to tell
me that I'm on taxiway bravoo I've heard
some Pilots use this little jingle black
Square you're there use that if you need
it but black sign with yellow letters
tells you your current locations and
location signs don't only show taxiway
locations they can show you which Runway
you're on as well so if I was cleared
for takeoff on Runway 4 left here and I
wanted to make sure I was on the correct
Runway this sign right here could
confirm that for me this is what we call
a Runway location sign okay so signs can
tell you where you are but they can also
tell you where to go one of the most
common signs that you'll see at an
airport is one of these guys right here
this is what we call a taxiway Direction
sign notice how it's a yellow sign with
black letters a taxiway Direction sign
like this tells you which direction to
turn if you want to go to this specific
taxi way so if I'm taxing here on
Charlie and I see this sign that lets me
know that I need to make a right turn
here if I want to turn on to Delta and
then once I turn on to Delta what sign
would I see that's right I'd see this
guy wouldn't I but Direction signs don't
just show you how to get to a taxi way
they can also show you how to get to a
specific location destination signs like
this tell you which way to turn if you
want to go to a specific destination as
you can see if I want a taxi to the
terminal this sign might be particularly
handy for me because it tells me that I
need to turn here if I want to get over
to the terminal Direction signs can even
tell you how to get to a specific Runway
this is called an outbound destination
sign just like the other direction signs
this guy's yellow with black lettering
but this guy's telling me that if I want
to take off on Runway 4 right all I have
to do is taxi straight ahead to get
there too easy right what about this guy
what do you think this one means we've
all seen this one before haven't we it
looks almost identical to the D not
enter signs you see on the road guess
what it means the exact same thing we
call it a no entry sign and this could
indicate a vehicle Road a walking path
or somewhere else where aircraft entry
is prohibited don't go in there with
your airplane things might not end up
too good for
[Music]
you he still in there he ain't happy
okay here's an interesting one this sign
has yellow diagonal stripes on a black
background this is what we call a
taxiway ending sign what do you think
that means that's right you will
literally fall off the edge of the Earth
if you taxi there I'm just kidding this
sign tells you that the taxi way is
ending you're not necessarily prohibited
but there's just not a taxi way there
taxi at your own risk in that area I
know what you thinking you've got to ask
yourself one question do I feel
lucky well do you
bunk okay there are a couple more signs
that you need to know about but these
almost always have ground markings
associated with them so let's move on
and talk about those ground markings
that you're going to see at an airport
now the purpose in taxiway markings is
fairly obvious just like the signs they
exist to help you take the correct paths
when you're taxi on an airport they can
also keep you from Crossing into areas
where you shouldn't be and these
markings are specifically designed so
that it's easy for you to see them from
your aircraft and that'll make it much
easier for to send you to prison when
you claim that you didn't see that
Runway hold line too bad we designed
them so you could easily see them I'm
just messing with you guys but don't
test them who knows what they're
actually capable of anyway let's start
by looking at some of the most important
taxiway markings you should know about
these are what we call holding position
markings and there are a few different
kinds first we have a really basic
single dash line this is simply a
holding position marking for an
intersecting taxi way this marking
allows you to determine where you need
to stop if ground or Tower tells you to
hold short of another taxi way not all
taxi way intersections have these
markings I personally think they only
put them on taxiways where it's not
obvious where you need to stop if you're
told to hold short November 3148 x-ray
hold short of Taxi way Bravo hold short
of Bravo November 3148 X-ray next we
have the runway holding position marking
now you may have heard this referred to
as a VFR hold line but don't let this
confuse you it doesn't matter if the
weather's VFR or not at a towered
Airfield you're required to stop before
this marking and get some kind of
clearance before you can cross this guy
now I know you can count so you probably
notice that this guy is made of four
yellow lines two solid lines and two
dash lines and I want you to think of
these kind of like a passing Lane
marking you see on a highway when you're
coming up to a runway for a takeoff the
two solid lines are going to be facing
you just like a passing Lane you cannot
pass this line until you get a clearance
of some kind if you're at a non powered
airport then this is where you should be
making a radio call and just making sure
that the runway is clear before taking
off now when you come up to one of these
lines there's usually going to be a red
sign like this with white letters this
guy lets you know which Runway you're
approaching and red signs like this are
what we call mandatory instruction signs
when you see one of these I want you to
think of these as a stop sign once again
stop here and get some kind of clearance
before you take the runway November 3148
x-ray clear for takeoff Runway 18 clear
for takeoff 18 November 314 x-ray all
right I'm clear for takeoff but which
way do I turn to get onto the runway do
I turn left or do I turn right this is
definitely something you don't want to
mess up and to keep you from messing it
up these mandatory instruction signs are
actually positioned so that it's obvious
which way you need to turn I like to
think of these guys as miniature runways
if I turn the numbers to the side and
make these signs into little runways
then it's pretty obvious in this example
I need to turn right to line up on
Runway 18 because my miniature Runway is
showing me that the beginning of Runway
18 is on the left and turning right will
put me on a heading of 18 now when
you're at the end of the runway like I
am here there's no way I could take off
from Runway 36 because there's no Runway
left because of that these mandatory
instruction signs will often depict one
Runway at one side okay so here's a
little quiz for you what if I hear this
from Tower when I'm holding short of
Runway 18 Skyhawk 3148 x-ray line up and
we Runway 18 line up and we 18 Skyhawk
3148 x-ray all right so I read back the
instructions perfectly but can I cross
the runway hold position marking if you
said yes then you're correct yes we do
need some kind of clearance to cross
these lines but this is a clearance
you'll get sometimes when you aren't
cleared for takeoff but Tower wants you
to get lined up on the runway so you can
make a quick takeoff once the Tower
decides that it's safe for you to do so
okay but what if I just landed and I'm
exiting a Runway where should I stop and
contact ground after I land first things
first don't ever just switch to ground
unless Tower tells you to do so if you
land on one Runway and you need a taxi
across another you may need to stay on
with Tower to be able to safely cross
that other Runway so the way you do that
is to taxi past the runway hold position
marking and when Tower switches you over
to ground contact them for for the taxi
clearance before you move anymore
Skyhawk 3148 x-ray contact ground on
121.9 121.9 Sky 314 x-ray remember this
is like a passing Lane so you can taxi
across the dash lines just stop when
you're completely over all four lines
now a lot of times you'll also see one
of these guys to show you exactly where
the whole position marking is and this
is called a boundary sign and once you
know for sure that you're past the whole
position line give ground a call and let
them know what you want ground Skyhawk
3148 xray clear of 18 at kilo request
taxi South general aviation parking
Skyhawk 314 and x-ray taxi South ramp
via Alpha Taxi South ramp via Alpha
Skyhawk 3148 x-ray all right here's
another holding position marking that
you need to know about this one is for
an ILS and typically you'll see this ILS
mandatory instruction sign beside this
guy now as a VFR pilot you're generally
not going to see these in use because
these holding lines are not typically
active unless the clouds are less than
800 ft or the visibility is less than 2
miles that being said both ground or
Tower can tell you to hold short of
these lines and if they do you have to
hold short of them the reason for this
is because when you taxi in front of
these lines you could disrupt the signal
from the ILS which allows pilots to make
Precision instrument approaches to that
Runway and believe me it is not good if
you mess up that signal for those guys
guys especially if they're in the clouds
now on the back side of these mandatory
instruction signs for the ILS you'll
typically find another boundary sign and
this one looks just like the markings on
the ground that way it's obvious when
you're clear those markings especially
if ATC ever tells you to taxi clear of
the ILS critical area that way you can
get out of the way in case somebody
needs to use the ILS all right when it
comes to taxiway markings there's a
couple other things you should know
about this is called an enhanced taxiway
Center Line and the only difference in
the traditional taxiway Center Line and
this enhanced taxiway Center Line are
these extra little Dash lines as you
approach the hold position marking these
Dash lines start about 150 ft from the
hold line and they just let you know to
be prepared to stop I guess the FAA was
tired of people crossing the hold lines
without permission or they got a great
deal on a bulk purchase of paint I don't
know but these enhanced taxiway center
lines are something you need to know
about for the written test then last but
not least we've got these markings right
here here and what would you imagine
these taxiway markings are for yep these
are roadway markings for ground Vehicles
sometimes they'll be zippered like this
and sometimes it'll look like a normal
road but this is something you should be
aware of so you don't run into a ground
vehicle when you least expect it in
addition to taxiway markings there's
also quite a few markings on runways you
should know about as well so let's move
on and talk about Runway markings for a
second now some of you guys already know
what these big numbers on a Runway mean
but for those of you who don't let's
spend a minute talk talking about that
because this is an important part of
making sure that you're landing and
taking off on the correct Runway Runway
numbers are kind of interesting when an
airport builds a Runway they typically
try to line them up with the prevailing
winds in that area and these runways are
numbered based on the magnetic direction
that they're pointing rounded to the
nearest 10° for example Runway 18 here
at Adams Field is pointed on a magnetic
heading about
180° so it's a southbound Runway and we
could actually find the exact Direction
This Runway points by looking at the
airport diagram looks like right now
with the current variation Runway 18 is
pointed exactly
181.50 de South that'll come in handy
later during instrument training but for
my Private Pilot students you just need
to be aware that the runway numbers
indicate a rough direction that the
runway's pointed this can keep you from
lining up on the wrong runway for
takeoffs and landings so if the wind is
coming from 185 at 15 knots which Runway
should we land on remember we want to
land into the wind and Runway 18 is
roughly on a heading of 180 so Runway 18
is the best runway for the current wind
conditions okay but what if we see a big
X like this at each end of the runway
what does that mean X's indicate that
the runway is closed for aircraft
operations and you should never take off
or land on a closed Runway unless it's
an absolute emergency keep in mind even
if a runways close there may still be
numbers painted on the runway Runway
closers can be temporary or permanent
and they typically leave the numbers on
them if they have intentions on opening
them back up at some point in both cases
Runway closur should be documented in
the nms but in addition to that runways
that are permanently closed will often
be depicted like this one here at
Stillwater Regional Airport notice how
they've drawn X's all the way down the
runway and the runway appears to be
disconnected in some places this Runway
is permanently closed and if we were to
look at this Runway from the air you
could actually see that this pavement is
in shambles and they've marked big X's
all the way down the pavement to let you
know that this is not somewhere you want
to land unless you've lost your engine
and you don't have much of a choice all
right here's another Runway marking you
should know about take a look at these
arrows on the runway over at
Bartlesville municipal airport arrows
like this before the threshold let you
know that the runway has a displaced
threshold this is important because
you're not allowed to land on this part
of the runway you can use it for taxi
and takeoff but landing is not allowed
displaced thresholds are typically
something you see when they want to keep
you from running into an obstruction at
the approaching of Runway or there's a
noise sensitive area that they want you
to stay high over it looks like here in
Bartlesville there's a highway just
south of the threshold so I'm guessing
they don't want you buzzing those cars
on the highway and scaring the tar out
of those
people now if you're like me a displaced
threshold is something that you want to
know about before you fly into an
Airfield
and one of the simplest ways you can use
to determine whether or not an airport
has A displaced threshold is to look for
this inverse D or what I like to call
the dirty D on the airport diagram if
the dirty D is present you can quickly
determine which runways have a displaced
threshold by looking for these squiggly
figure eights at the approach into of
the runway and now that I know that this
Runway has a display threshold I won't
be cut off guard and accidentally land
in front of the threshold remember I can
use this to taxi or take off I just
can't land there remember if you see
white arrows that means you can taxi and
take off you just can't land but there
are some areas at the end of a Runway
where you're not allowed to do anything
take a look back at our runways over
here at Ted Stevens International
Airport up in Anchorage Alaska most of
you probably already notice these areas
in front of the runway threshold that
are marked with yellow chevrons these
are what we call emergency overrun areas
when you see yellow chevrons like this
these mean that you can't land taxi or
take off from this part of the runway in
fact you shouldn't do any kind of normal
operations at all in these areas these
are here for emergency purposes only
they're usually not built to handle much
weight and if you do use them you could
potentially damage your aircraft and the
pavement but in an emergency they could
come in really handy to keep you from
completely leaving the pavement now just
like a displac threshold emergency
overrun areas are also marked on the
airport diagram these areas are shown as
these light gray areas in front of the
black runways so if I see these on my
Airport diagram then I know that they're
going to have those yellow chevrons on
them and that means that I cannot use
them unless it's an absolute emergency
and I'm trying to crash my airplane
without dying okay before we move on I
want to show you one more thing that you
need to know for the written test notice
here that it is possible to have an
overrun area and a displac threshold on
the same Runway and if you look closely
there's a yellow line that separates the
two of them this is what we call a
demarcation bar and this line basically
shows you where the overrun area ends
and where the displac threshold begins
now if you look over in the aim in
section
2-3-4 you'll notice that there can
actually be a few different things that
start in front of a displaced threshold
this can be anything from a taxi way to
a stopway or even a blastp pad in all
these examples a demarcation bar like
this lets you know where those things
end and where the display threshold
begins and remember you cannot land on
any of these areas you can taxi and take
off from this area with the white Arrow
but you cannot land on anything but the
actual Runway where you see these
markings that look like piano keys okay
time for a pop quiz let's say I'm taking
my FAA written exam and they show me
this picture right here first of all
which Runway should I land on keep in
mind this is kind of a trick question
first of all we need to determine which
way the wind is blowing and I know it
might look like it but this is not a
wind sock this is actually what we call
a tetrahedron and these things work a
lot like a Weather Vein so the wind is
actually coming from the southwest here
like this okay so if the wind is coming
from the southwest then ideally we'd
want to land into the wind but
unfortunately Runway 22 here is closed
isn't it so we can't land there because
of that we have to settle for Runway 18
that means that as we land we're going
to be dealing with a slight right to
left crosswind but there's one more
thing we want to keep in mind as we're
landing on 18 and what do you think that
is yep that's right we need to land
beyond the displac threshold there you
guys are getting this no problem all
right there's one more thing I want to
talk to you guys about in today's lesson
and that's airport lighting now I'm not
going to tell you about all the lights
you're going to see at an airport if I
did we'd be here all night and that
would be super boring but let's talk
about some of the things that I think
you should know when it comes to airport
lighting first things first how can we
tell the difference in a Runway and a
taxi way when we're flying at night
that's right the lights surrounding
those areas are different colors
taxiways can be identified by blue
lights that are placed on the edge of
the taxi way occasionally at bigger
airports you might see green lights that
Mark the center of the taxi way but the
edge lights are marked with blue runways
on the other hand are typically
surrounded by white lights now this may
very well be the most important piece of
information that could keep you from
accidentally landing on a taxi way at
night instead of a Runway if you see
blue that's not where you want to land
always aim for the white but here's
something else that's kind of handy when
you need to know how much runway you
have in front of you most run runways
with instrument approaches also have
yellow lights surrounding the last 2,000
ft of the runway or the last half of the
runway whichever is less this is good to
know if you're floating down the runway
and you're concerned about the runway
length in front of you keep in mind when
you fly at Night the Lights have a
tendency to make things look different
but the key is to do everything the way
you normally would I've often found that
the runway lights make me feel higher
than I actually am and if you flare too
low The Landing might not turn out the
greatest I found that when I remind
myself that I'm lower than I think my
Landings end up being much better but if
you're struggling with night Landings
you may want to change the brightness of
the lights on the Airfield now at
towered airfields the tower can usually
change the brightness of the runway and
taxi lights if you just ask them but at
most unattended airports they often have
pilot controlled lighting check the
chart supplement to see exactly what
your airport has and what frequency to
use but if your Airfield has pilot
controlled lighting typically you can
operate that by clicking your mic a
specific amount of times within 5
seconds on most Lighting systems you
usually have to start with the brightest
setting first and to do this most
systems are set up so that you have to
click the mic seven times within 5
Seconds to get the lights to come on
from there you can change to a medium
brightness by clicking the mic five
times in 5 seconds or you can turn them
on low by clicking the mic three times
in 5 seconds play around with this and
see what setting you prefer when you
make your night Landings but pay
attention pilot controlled lighting
typically only stays stays on for 15
minutes after you last keyed the mic you
don't want to be starting the round out
and then the lights go out on
you thank you guys for watching today's
video on Airport markings and Airport
lighting if you enjoyed this video
please smash that like button for me if
you've been watching my complete ground
course you're getting super close to
knowing everything you need to know for
the written test but if you haven't
started that ground course you can start
that right here and when I finish with
the next lesson I'll throw that right
here for you guys see